is it too late now to say sorry
yeah it's looking that way for company h
m after Justin Bieber called them out
over Instagram on Monday for releasing
products allegedly using his likeness
without his permission fever took to his
insta stories to let his 270 million
followers know
I didn't approve any of the merch
collection that they put up at h m all
without my permission and approval shake
my head I wouldn't buy it if I were you
in another insta story Bieber adds the h
m merch they made of me is trash and I
didn't approve it don't buy it okay the
clothing in question includes a sweater
dress with a black and white picture of
the singer's face
a canvas bag with different photos of
beaver printed on the front and a few
other clothing items featuring Bieber's
likeness
h m also included a few clothing items
that say World Tour and are associated
with the singer
and used lyrics from his song ghost that
reads I miss you more than life on a
hoodie and a cell phone
[Music]
[Applause]
Bieber also responded to a fan account
on Instagram that posted the clothing
from h m writing when everyone finds out
I didn't approve any of this merch shake
my head
in response to Bieber's public message a
spokesperson from h m tells Forbes as
with all other licensed products and
Partnerships h m followed proper
approval procedures